[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction nous sommes le 22 décembre
voici les principaux titres en image
dans 48h nous fêterons Noël et au-delà
des cadeaux c'est aussi l'occasion de
profiter d'un bon repas l'heure pour les
familles et donc aux dernières courses
le vent des globes se poursuit et vous
verrez que vous pouvez tranquillement y
participer derrière votre écran
d'ordinateur un jeu sur internet permet
d'accompagner les skippers et puis
dernier volet de notre rétrospective
2016 pour cette semaine aujourd'hui nous
revenons sur les principaux événements
politiques de la primaire de la droite
et du centre au nouveaux maire élu à
guillencour et à laavrière j- 2 avant le
réveillon de Noël les commerçants de
voisin le Bretonneux notamment font face
aux dernières commandes boucherie
caviste poissonnier cette période est
souvent charnière pour ce secteur ils
peuvent gagner jusqu'à 30 % de l' leur
chiffre d'affaires annuel pendant cette
période justement le reportage de Michel
elmidoro et de Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude le compte à rebourg avant Noël a
débuté chez les commerçants le rythme
s'accélère pour pouvoir répondre aux
commandes des clients chez ce cavist
implanté à voisin le bretonux depuis 17
ans on prépare les stocks en amont pour
anticiper ce dernier rush moi dès
septembre je rentre déjà des produits
par rapport au fait de fin d'année il
une petite astuce aussi c'est que les
produits souvent les producteurs
augmentent leur prix en prévision des
fêites plus on se' rapproche plus les
produits vont être chers donc nous on
prend un peu de marge de manœuvre on
achète en amont de façon à pouvoiroser
des produits à des prix qui tiennent la
route quoi et qui soient pas prohibitifs
les whisky les champagnes sont les BA
celleur de ces périodes de fête 2016
mais certains préfèrent les alcools
traditionnels voà j'ai pris un arm
maniaac pour mon père en fait parce que
c'est un fan bien faire l'adéquation
c'estz important de savoir placer bah un
bon vin et puis derrière s'il a un
digestif
c'est important à quelques mètres dans
cette boucherie les clients sont trois
fois plus nombreux qu'en temps normal
les commandes sont passées généralement
4 à 5 jours avant le repas du réveillon
et bien une poularde pour les fêtes de
Noël nous sommes que que quatre et donc
je profite de la bonne viande de ce
boucher pour pour commander pour
répondre à cette demande les 10 bouchers
de la structure n'hésitent pas à faire
des heures supplémentaire c'est commeême
des journées longues et même le soir
quand on ferme à 19h30 on est obligé
parce qu'on fait beaucoup de préparation
maison beaucoup de de purée beaucoup de
choses en croûte et tout ça donc c'est
fait maison c'est c'est très long à
faire pas de répis non plus pour les
poissonniers les fêtes de Noël sont
aussi un moment charnière pour le
secteur cette structure viinoise réalise
près de 30 % de son chiffre d'affaires
annuel au mois de décembre des gens
commence à chercher des produits genre
coquille Saint-Jacques coqu
Saint-Jacques
langou les gens se renseignent beaucoup
sur le sur le tarif mais sinon c'est
Saint-Jacques saumon lotte bar pour se
réveiller en 2016 le budget moyen pour
un repas traditionnel ser les 35 € par
convive de quoi vous mettre l'eau à la
bouche les enfants sont en vacances
depuis près d'une semaine et l'attente
pour les cadeaux pour l'arrivée du Père
Noël peut-être longue pour patienter au
Petit Moulin des veau de cernet les
équipes ont proposé des séances des
comptes de la et du vent une centaine de
personnes a pu en profiter comme l'a
constaté sur place Mélanie poet les
cerises c'est au printemps c'est à la
fin du printemps dans 6 mois
oui je
sais mais le temps que j'arrive
elle sera
mure des histoires courte et amusante
pour ses vacances de Noël Le Petit
Moulin des veau de cerné a invité une
compteuse et la période est toute
trouvée on associe les contes à Noël
parce que
peut-être voilà dans l'imaginaire des
gens le merveilleux les rassemble mais
ce que nous disent les conttes c'est que
le merveilleux est partout toujours tout
le temps et que si on le veut bien c'est
tous les jours
Noël une petite salle est dédiée au
compte pour une intimité loin du musée
le Moulin propose des activités ludiques
en plus de l'aspect historique et cette
première a du succès
c'était bien j'ai bien aimé toutes les
histoires et j'ai bien ch j'ai aimé qu'
on chantait trois séances de comptte ont
été proposés une centaine de personnes
petits et grands en a profité peut-être
pour faire passer le temps plus vite et
oui plus que quelques jours à
patienter et on quitte l'univers de Noël
pour le dernier volet de notre
rétrospective 2016 après le sport la
culture les sujets de société nous
revenons à présent sur les événements
marquant en matière de politique pour
2016 L'ANNÉE POLITIQUE débute en janvier
par la tenue du premier conseil
communautaire d'un Saint-Quentin en
iveline dorénavant composé de 12
communes au revoir la casquie et bonjour
à Skille Michel logier maire divivers
droite de Montini le Bretonneux conserve
la présidence c'est une nouvelle
aventure parce que c'est déjà un nouveau
territoire c'est un nouveau territoire
avec d'autres enjeux on regarder tout
simplement aujourd'hui nous avions trois
gares sur le territoire nous en aurons
se nous avons se désormais une nouvelle
aventure qui débute mal avec une
opposition de gauche qui refuse de
prendre part au premier vote s'estimant
exclus de la gouvernance les tensions se
poursuivront tout au long de l'année des
tensions également entre le département
des ivelines et l'État les élus du
conseil départemental engagent un bras
de faire avec le gouvernement suite à la
diminution des dotations versées une
diminution de 288 millions d'euros en
septembre une manifestation avait lieu
devant l'Assemblée nationale ce sont des
sommes absolument considérables que
l'État ne nous donne plus plus alors que
il décide de nos dépenses les dépenses
sociales et il ne compense pas alors que
normalement il a cette obligation
constitutionnelle face à des ressources
en chute les ivelines tentent de se
rapprocher des haut de scènees pour
mutualiser les moyens en juin un premier
budget commun était voté 2017 sera une
année électorale chargée entre
présidentielle sénatoriale et
législative et les différentes campagnes
ont débuté dès cette année la primaire
de la droite et du centre a vu la
victoire de François Fillon François
Fillon largement en tête également dans
les Yvelines avec plus de 66 % de la
primaire on retiendra également la
candidature du député yvelino à
président du parti chrétiendémocrate
Jean-Frédéric Poisson inconnu du grand
public il a marqué les débats avec des
prises de position sur plusieurs sujets
de société et c'est pendant cette
primaire à droite que s'est préparée la
primaire de la gauche verdict en janvier
2017 un ivelinois est là aussi en course
Benoît Hamont député socialiste en
campagne il poursuit sa critique du
gouvernement qui l' a quitté en 2014
enfin 2016 aura été marqué sur 550 an en
Eveline par deux départs de m en mars
c'était un lin àage qui pour des raisons
de santé laissé Néli duutu prendre la
tête de l'une des dernières villes
communistes d'île-de-fance comme
toujours dans ces moments-l on espère
que les choses vont s'améliorer
s'arranger euh c'est pas tout à fait le
cas j'ai ma situation de santé a encore
besoin d'attention de soins en octobre
François delignier maire PS de
guilloncour depuis 14 ans passerit lui
la main à Marie-Christine le tarneek une
décision qu'il dit avoir prise afin de
préparer l'avenir et l'intégralité de
ces rétrospectives de l'année 2016 est à
retrouver sur notre site Internet grâce
au Replay et également sur vos
téléphones mobiles et sur vos tablettes
grâce aux applications TVfil disponibles
depuis quelques jours on passe au sport
maintenant avec le vend des globes 2016
qui ne se dispute pas dispute pas
uniquement sur mer et dans les océans
mais aussi en ligne sur Internet plus de
360000 skipper virtuel débutants ont
confirmé ont ainsi pris le départ des
sables d'olon c'était le 6 novembre
dernier au sein de l'entreprise bureau
valet qui soutient notamment un skipper
un vrai celui-ci le skipper rambolitin
Louis Burton certains salariés ont
décidé de se lancer dans l'aventure de
partager c'est cette aventure avec lui
Michel el midoro est donc allé au siège
social de cette entreprise qui est basée
au clés
sousbois le 6 novembre dernier le
skipper Louis Burton originaire de
Rambouillet prenit le départ du V globe
2016 à bord de son imoka bureau Vallé
long en
la pour partager l'aventure du skipper
dans le siège social de bureau Vallé au
clés sous-bois une trentaine d'employés
se sont improvisé capitaine sur le jeu
virtuel regata une simulation en ligne
du vent des globes ouvert à tous créé en
2006 parmi ces marins d'ous on retrouve
le directeur de projet Nicolas strugarek
j'avais envie de suivre Louis tous les
jours et donc de faire suivre aussi les
aventures de Louis à ma famille et
virtual rugata c'est un bon moyen de se
coller à l'aventure sans subir tous les
tous les aléas qu'on peut avoir en mer
sur ce jeu Nicolas doit se mettre dans
la peau d'un véritable skipper les
joueurs ont les mêmes vents et la même
météo en temps réel il faut aussi régler
ses voiles et fixer son cap
régulièrement son objectif é clair comme
les eaux du Pacifique terminé devant
Louis Burton j'ai pris quelques quelques
quelques options un peu différente de
Louis et maintenant on est complètement
collé au bout de 40 jours on est on est
quasiment au même niveau sachant qu'on
on était pas du tout parti sur les mêmes
options au début je sais qu'il est plus
fort que moi mais j'ai la chance de pas
avoir tous les tous les chaos qui pe y
avoir en mer donc oui effectivement
j'aimerais bien arriver avant lui les
deux concurrents viennent d'atteindre le
stade de la mi-course au large de
l'Australie rendez-vous début février
pour savoir qui remportera la victoire
entre Nicolas et le navigateur
yvelinois et pour participer à ce tour
du monde en solitaire et sans Escal les
skipers ont besoin de sponsor et de
messen afin de financer un B à plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros et
l'équipement dernière génération
installé à bord jeudi dernier les 14
sponsors du versaillais Éric bélion se
sont réunis à Paris à côté de la tour FL
pour discuter de ce projet la société
sales force a investi près de 900000 €
sur 3 ans pour accompagner le navigateur
dans son périple on écoute son directeur
général Olivier deien j'ai adéré à à
deux éléments essentiels d'abord
l'homérique et son parcours et sa façon
de raconter ses histoires
la sincérité qu'il dégage et ensuite à
titre égal j'aurais tendance à dire les
valeurs et les valeurs de son projet
quand la raison et le cœur se rejoignent
et bien c'est arrivé ensuite il Fall en
interne que je que je combatte quelques
quelques idées reçu parce que tout le
monde était d'accord avec moi mais
personne ne voulait me donner l'argent
toujours pareil à la fin j'ai réussi à
trouver l'argent et on a mis tout le
monde d'accord fin de ce journal
rendez-vous le lundi 2 janvier 18h pour
nouveau direct et un nouveau point
complet sur l'actualité locale
l'actualité du département des ivelines
demain dernière Hebdo de l'année 2016
vous sera le dernier Hebdo vous sera
présenté par Nicolas kirilovitz en
attendant les programmes se poursuivent
sur notre
[Musique]
antenne